he was the king of kungfu the deadliest
human fighting machine that the world
had ever seen bringing a new level of
excitement to the silver screen he
established himself as the first
oriental superstar billed as the fittest
man on the planet he has the world at
his feet then suddenly he was gone
dead at the age of 32 in the almost 50
years since then his legend has
propelled Bruce Lee to mythical
proportions in this week's biographic
s-- we go beyond the legends and reveal
the real Bruce Lee
[Music]
the child who the world would know as
Bruce Lee was born on November 27 4 1940
in the Jackson Street Hospital in San
Francisco's Chinatown his mother Grace
Lee was accompanying her husband's the
actor Hoyt young on a tour of the United
States with the Cantonese opera company
of Hong Kong grace named the child Zhu
Fang meaning returned again that's the
doctor delivering him nicknamed him
Bruce the Lee's stayed in San Francisco
for five months before returning to Hong
Kong but the heat and the humidity of
Asia did not agree with baby Bruce
he became a sickly child with his mother
constantly doting on him Grace has
already lost to Charles and was
determined that she would not lose a
second as he grew older Bruce became
stronger in fact he became so active
that his mother nicknamed him never sit
still the only time he stopped running
jumping or striking the air was when he
was curled up in the corner with a book
in his hands his long hours of reading
into the night caused him to become
nearsighted and at age six he required
reading glasses
Bruce grew up in a crowded little flat
along with his family there was that of
his late brother so that nearly 20
people were squashed into the chaotic
household still the Lee's were among the
wealthiest of families in Hong Kong
along with his opera income how John
received payments from rental properties
Bruce spent much of his time and musing
himself on the streets of Hong Kong he
showed little interest in school and
would often cut class to hang out on the
streets with local hoods by the time he
was 10 he had developed a pension for
practical jokes these started out
innocent enough but soon took on a more
sinister touch once he pushed his sister
Phoebe into a swimming pool she
retaliated by holding his head under the
water until he promised to never do it
again
from that day on he promised you'd never
go in a swimming pool again
bruce's acting career began at just
three months thanks to his father's
connections in the local entertainment
industry his first real acting role
occurred when he was six years old he
played a rebellious street kid in the
movie beginning of a boy in that film he
had the first of many on-screen fights
he was building this and a string of
films that followed as Lee su Leung or
Lee little dragon Bruce loved the life
of a young actor often he would be
picked up at 2:00 a.m. leaping from his
beds and excitedly rushing out the door
in his later films he played teenage
rebels who invariably ended up in a
climactic fight scene from the very
start he developed certain trademark
mannerisms which would later become
famous
the admonishing finger the thumb wiped
across his nose the steady unflinching
gaze by the time he was 18 Bruce had
appeared in 20 films the most famous of
which was the orphan which was his only
indeed in role
[Applause]
[Music]
at the age of 12 Bruce began attending
La Salle College a Catholic boy school
his teachers there found him to be lazy
stubborn and rebellious the Chinese
students of Bruce's school felt a strong
rivalry with the British students who
attended King George v school which was
up the hill Bruce became the leader of a
gang that hung out after school behind
the playing field of the rival school
the boys would shout taunts at the
British students often with the result
that fierce fistfights would break out
the rumbles they were often broken up by
the police phone calls and visits by the
police became a regular occurrence at
the Lee household his father was furious
at the wayward course that Bruce was
taking and imposed strict restrictions
on him but he was not home enough for
them to have any real effect with
fighting becoming a major part of his
life Bruce began thinking about the
subject most of the time he later
recalled that he always fought with his
gang behind him using chairs as weapons
but what would happen he wondered if he
got caught on his own without his gang
to back him up could he protect himself
he decided not to take any chances and
became convinced that in order to
survive he needed to be trained in the
most effective of the martial arts kung
fu'
Bruce's father had taught him some Tai
Chi moves but the slow flowing movements
were little help in a street fight at
the age of 13 he began learning Wing
Chun under trainer William young Bruce
threw himself into his lessons
practicing constantly and making rapid
progress Young was so impressed with his
young students that he introduced him to
his master a revered older man named Yip
man the master decided to take on Bruce
as a personal student at first Bruce was
only interested in learning how to
street fight but as the lessons
continued Yip man introduced him to the
finer points of the art meditation
breathing and balance while training
under yep Bruce learns not only to
master the physical techniques but also
to quell the interference of emotions
such as fear and anger despite his
developing skills as a martial artist
Bruce was still a troublemaker at school
at age 15 he was expelled from the South
College and in our third sin Francis
Xavier College on the other side of town
one of his teachers their brother Edward
encouraged ruse to release his energies
by entering the 1958 boxing
championships held between his new
school and King George the fifth school
Bruce likes the idea and trained
vigorously for the upcoming challenge
when the competition finally took place
Bruce breezed his way through the
preliminary rounds knocking out three
opponents in the first round in the
final he faced Gary Elms who had held
the title for the last three years Bruce
was able to use the blocking moves he
had learned from wind Cheung to negate
the power of his opponent then in the
third round he landed a devastating blow
which put Elms on the canvas Bruce had
won the title despite having the
prestige of being the Intercity boxing
champ Bruce continued to get in trouble
both with his teachers and the police
finally his mother suggested that he
returns the country of his birth to
claim citizenship before he turned 18 at
which time it would be too late his
father agreed
knowing that Bruce's future depended on
him getting away from his peers
on April 15th 1959 Bruce gathered up his
meager belongings and set off for his
three-week journey across the Pacific
before he left his mother slipped $100
into his pocket and his father gave him
a further 15 dollars he was booked onto
the ship as a third class passenger that
spent most of his time in first class by
giving dance lessons to other passengers
on May the 17th he fulfilled his
mother's prophecy when she named him
returning to the place of his birth San
Francisco
Bruce stayed with a friend of his father
making a meager income by giving dance
lessons during his first few months in
San Francisco he met several local
karate students who encouraged him to
teach kung fu' but Bruce he was not yet
ready to make that leap a few months
after arriving he moved into the
boarding house really Chou the family
friends and he began to work as a waiter
in a restaurant he also enrolled in
Edison Technical High School when
Seattle hell's an Asian culture day
teachers at the school asked Bruce to
give a kung fu demonstration in the
audience that day was James DeMille
former US Army heavyweight boxing champ
scanning the audience Bruce noticed
DeMille and invited him up to spar with
him
DeMille thought he could easily take out
slide Chinamen but was surprised to
discover that he was unable to lay a
finger on Bruce who was able to block
and counter with deadly efficiency after
the demonstration DeMille asked Bruce to
teach him some moves
before long Bruce had a devoted core of
serious students
Bruce applied himself to his education
for the first time earning his diploma
from Edison Tech with high enough grades
to be admitted to the University of
Washington in Seattle while at college
he kept up with his kung fu training but
he would not let his teaching come
before his own learning he would train
for up to 40 hours each week developing
new techniques and borrowing from all
forms in order to create the most
functional fighting style in October of
1963 22 year old Bruce quit his job at
Ruby Chows restaurants and opened his
own training academy the Jun fan gung
foo Institute's
he lived at the back in a small
windowless room it was around this time
the Bruce also met a fellow student at
Washington by the name of Linda Emery
they began dating though Linda hid the
budding romance from her parents the
Institute did well and by 1964 Bruce was
ready to open up a larger queen in
Oakland California he closed the door of
the first Academy man told his assistant
tacky camera to reopen the school in
Chinatown as a private club for his
regular students before opening the
Auckland Queen Bruce attended the
International karate tournament in Long
Beach where he had been invited to give
a demonstration here he wowed the crowd
with his soon-to-be famous one-inch
punch it was here the Bruce also first
met Filipino martial artist dan inosanto
who would become his number one students
Bruce gave further demonstrations and
soon had a thriving business in Oakland
his plan was to build up a nest egg and
then bring Linda from Seattle where they
would marry but those plans were swept
aside when Linda wrote to Bruce saying
that she was pregnant Bruce he was
delighted despite the protestations of
Linda's family they were married in a
small ceremony on August the 17th 1964
Bruce and his new bride moved in with
James Lee and his family
James was a traditionally trained kungfu
man who was looking for a more
practically efficient style he worked
with Bruce to build up his Oakland's
kowloon they offered their skills to
anyone who was seriously interested in
learning how to fight in early 1965 a
traditional Chinese kung-fu instructor
named Wong Jack man Hearns VPAP with
teaching Chinese secret fighting arts to
Westerners he was enraged and largely to
build his own reputation he challenged
ruse to a fight with a wager the loser
would have to close his school when Wong
turned up for the fight he half expected
Bruce to back down but Bruce was hyped
and ready for action a surprised Wong
tried to throw in some last minute rules
no I Japs no groin kicks etc but Bruce
rejected them saying I'm not standing
for any of that you've made the
challenge it's all out it's no holds
barred the match was sloppy
after a few weak punches Wong turned to
run Bruce ran after him and punched him
in the back of the head but he couldn't
land a finishing punch Wong finally gave
up and his entourage dragged him off
without a word
Bruce was not happy with his showing the
fight had been too messy and he had
become winded it spurred him on to begin
an intense regimen of physical training
which he would keep up for the rest of
his life
[Music]
On February the 1st 1965 Linda gave
birth to a son Brandon
three days later Bruce was given his
first Hollywood screen test hair stylist
to the stars Jay Sebring had been in
attendance at the Long Beach karate
tournaments where Bruce had demonstrated
his one-inch punch and it mentions him
producers who were casting roles in a
new Charlie Chan movie he didn't get
that role but he was offered another
role as Kato the sidekick to the Green
Hornet in a projected TV series the
series premieres on September the 9th
1966 introducing American audiences to
kung fu for the first time young viewers
were amazed at what they saw and Kato
the sidekick soon became the real star
of the show Bruce began making personal
appearances all over the country
unfortunately the Green Hornet wasn't
such a hit with a dolt audiences who saw
it is too unrealistic and too much of a
copycat of Batman
after 26 weekly episodes it was canceled
despite his popularity as Kato no new
roles popped up for Bruce he did manage
to make a little cash with guest
appearances on long street blondie and
here comes the bride's once again though
he turned his energies to teaching kung
fu although he never intended it his
techniques soon developed into a new
fighting school he called it Jeet Kune
Do the way of the intercepting fist in
February of 1967 Bruce opened his third
kun in alleys Chinatown just a few
blocks from Dodger Stadium at the
suggestion of the Green Hornet's
assistant producer he raised his fees
from $22 per month to as much as $50 per
hour eventually his rates went up to
$250 per hour with director Roman
Polanski even flying in outer
Switzerland for private lessons
celebrity students included Steve
McQueen Lee Corbin and Kareem
abdul-jabbar he also trained established
martial art masters including Chuck
Norris Joe Lewis and Mike Stone between
them those three had won every major
karate championship in the United States
on April the 19th 1969 Linda gave birth
to a daughter Shannon a few weeks later
Bruce suffered a severe back injury
while lifting a 125 pound barbell the
doctor told him to forget kung fu he
would never kick again for 3 months he
lay flat on his back and fell into a
deep depression after six months he
finally began training again working
through his pain in a short amount of
time he was back to his own self it was
at the same time the Bruce was working
with screenwriter Stirling silicon's and
actor Lee Marvin on what was to
his breakout film the silent flute the
film never got to the shooting stage but
Sullivan did get Bruce a cameo on the TV
series Longstreet shortly after shooting
the Longstreet episode Bruce flew to
Hong Kong to arrange for is now widowed
mother to come and live in the United
States when he stepped off the plane he
was shocked at the reaction the Green
Hornet's have been playing in movie
theatres and it had made Bruce a Chinese
hero he was bombarded by reporters and
spent the next two weeks doing the
rounds of the local TV talk shows
Bruce's Fame did not escape the
attention of the key players in the Hong
Kong film industry the Shaw Brothers
they produced two-thirds of the Chinese
films in the world theirs was a film
production assembly line with actors and
crew being grossly underpaid they
offered Bruce a seven year contract for
just $2,000 per film and he turned them
down then Bruce was approached by
Raymond chow of Golden Harvest Studios
who offered $15,000 for two movies Bruce
while he signed on the dotted line and
the rest as they say is history
Bruce's first major role as an adult was
in the big boss the film was shot in
Bangkok in the middle of a heat wave
with no air-conditioning polluted water
and no fresh food
it was hardly the star's life that Bruce
had dreamed of but it was all worth it
because he was finally on his way the
BigBoss premiered in October of 1971
Bruce and Linda sat in the audience in
nervous anticipation the movie ended to
complete silence than utter chaos broke
out the ecstatic crowd practically
mobbed Bruce as he tried to leave the
theatre within three weeks the film took
in more than three million dollars in
Hong Kong smashing all records
Bruce's second film for Golden Harvest
fists of fury was even more popular
smashing the record set by the big boss
on the streets sold out tickets went for
$50 a pop Bruce had become a superstar
almost overnight suddenly he was unable
to walk down the street without drawing
a crowd returning to the United States
Bruce was excited about a new TV series
that was in production tentatively
called the warrior it was the story of a
Chinese Shaolin monk who gets
transplanted in the American West
Bruce desperately wanted the part yet he
was shocked and disappointed to learn
that he was considered too Chinese for
the role remember here that he was
supposed to play the role of a Chinese
man
the part was actually given to an
American actor named David Carradine and
retitled kung foo briefs dealt with this
rejection by throwing himself into his
next project a film he wrote by himself
called the
of the dragon he decided to do this one
completely by himself he would produce
direct cast choreograph Scout locations
and star in the movie he even played
percussion for the movie soundtrack the
movie was shot on a 130 thousand dollar
budget on location in Rome in the
climactic scene
Bruce recreated a one-on-one
gladiatorial contests with Chuck Norris
way of the Dragon was a smash hit taken
in 5.5 million dollars in Hong Kong
alone in the wake of its release Bruce
had planned to take some time off to
recover from his grueling schedule but
in October of 1972 he heard that a
basketball star Kareem abdul-jabbar was
in Hong Kong he quickly arranged some
action sequences with his 7-foot 2-inch
former students that could be used in
this next project Game of Death having
shot 20 minutes of footage for Game of
Death Bruce finally got the call from
Hollywood that he had been waiting for
for so long
Warner Brothers now saw Bruce as a
bankable commodity they wanted him to
star in a US martial arts film and were
willing to give him complete control
over the fight seems the entire feature
was caught enter the dragon the filming
of Enter the Dragon placed enormous
demands on Bruce's physical energy he
couldn't sleep at night he lost weight
and to skin pales and he started to look
ill
with filming wrapped up Bruce sat in a
tiny dubbing room on May the 10th 1973
looping dialogue in order to achieve
complete silence the air conditioning
was shut off Bruce went to the bathroom
to wash his face and collapsed he was
seized with a fit of vomiting and
struggled to breathe rush to hospital he
was diagnosed with cerebral edema and
then released around noon on January the
20th 1973 Bruce sat in his Hong Kong
study hunched over his books and papers
around 2:00 p.m. Raymond chow arrived to
discuss script ideas for Game of Death
staying for two hours in the early
evening Bruce drove over to the
apartment of bet eating pain and actress
who had wanted to play a lead role in
the film around 7:30
Bruce complained of a headache and arse
Betty if he could lie on her bed the
parrot planned to meet him and shower
was a restaurant for dinner
when Betty went in to rouse Bruce she
was unable to wake him she called Xiao
who rushed over unable to wake Bruce
they called for a doctor the martial
arts superstar he was rushed to hospital
but nothing could be done Bruce Lee was
dead on the cusp of worldwide domination
the world's fittest man was gone but the
legends of Bruce Lee
while that was just beginning so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic s-- if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday we
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
you